[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number three
if I were to swap my DNA with a cat's
DNA what I transform into a cat when I
woke up this morning I was scrolling
through my youtube comments on my other
YouTube channel stated clearly and under
the video what is DNA and how does it
work
I found this question and this is
probably one of my favorite questions
that I have ever gotten on my youtube
channel it's a really cool thing to try
and think about what would happen if I
were able to just swap my DNA with a
cat's DNA now first of all this would be
extremely difficult to do because every
single one of your cells has its very
own copy of your entire genome your
entire genetic code so you would have to
actually swap out the DNA in each one of
your whatever 20-something odd trillion
cells in your body you would have to
swap out your DNA with your cat's DNA
and that would not be a very easy task
we don't have the technology to do that
but difficulties aside what would happen
if you did do that would you transform
into a cat sadly the answer is no you
would not and the reason for that is
that your body has already developed the
cake has been baked taking a baked cake
and putting it into a new cake pan will
not transform the shape of that cake and
unfortunately that's also true if you
were to just immediately switch your DNA
with a cat's DNA your genome has within
it what we call fetal isoforms these are
versions of genes that only exist when
you are a fetus and these fetal genes
help guide your body as it's developing
once your body begins to mature and take
its adult form and this starts even when
you're a child certain fetal genes turn
off and the adult isoforms turn on and
that that changes slowly as you're going
as you're developing from a fetus to a
child front you know again as you're
going through puberty and so on until
you become an adult so these
different developmental genes have
already been turned on and turned off
and they've already been dancing and
playing back and forth with each other
and creating all these different
proteins that interact with each other
in different ways to form your body how
it formed simply changing your DNA now
as an adult or as no I I don't know how
old you are dear viewer but if you were
just to suddenly swap out your DNA with
a cat's DNA it wouldn't go back and
reverse all of that development and then
redo it as a cat so okay you get it you
wouldn't actually transform into a cat
but what would happen would you start
making cat proteins the answer there
probably is no as well the reason for
that is that you know humans and cats we
actually share a lot of the same genes
but those genes are in different spots
on our chromosomes and if you're just to
take the DNA out of a cell the human DNA
out of one of your cells and replace it
with cat DNA all of this the cell
machinery all those proteins and
ribozymes and little snippets of RNA
that exist in the cell nucleus along
with the DNA they would be lost
it would break the Machine essentially
because everything's located in
different spots the whole thing would
break the cell would die and because you
just replaced all the DNA and all of
your cells with cat DNA you would
immediately die as well okay so that's
not going to work because the protein
machinery inside the cell wouldn't
recognize that immediately swapped DNA
but what if we just said okay cats share
a lot of the same genes with humans but
those genes are slightly mutated there's
their slight differences in those genes
here I'm talking about protein coding
genes so what if we were to just swap
out the protein coding genes of a cat
with the protein coding genes of a human
then what would happen in that case I
believe that what would happen is that
your cells would start using those genes
and making cat proteins and that might
sound cool like maybe I'll get some
special abilities maybe we could see
better in the dark or something
unfortunately what I think would happen
is that your immune system would
go nuts and start attacking all of your
own cells you would die almost instantly
of a horrible autoimmune disease the
reason for that is that these cat
proteins are slightly different than
human proteins and your immune system
would see those as foreign objects and
attack and this would happen even if the
immune system at its genes replaced with
the cat genes as well because it's
already been trained to recognize your
body proteins as appropriate proteins
and all other proteins as invaders so
you would get yeah you would die
unfortunately next question